Tên trào, tủ đối lâm thời hút dạy phẩm, Trung tâm tủ đối khám chiến, là nơi diễn ra nhiều sự kiện lịch sử quan trọng của sinh tục Việt Nam trong cách mạng thẳng tảm và chiến năm triều kỳ khám chiến trống thực sinh pháp.
Đã tảm mấy năm trời qua, các thế hệ hôm nay đang phátwi chuyển thống cách mạng, sử dự quay hương ngày càng sâu đẹp.
Thẳng năm năm 1970, trước những diễn biến mâu lệ và yêu cầu của tình hình cách mạng, mắc hồ chuyển từ câu bằng về tuyên quan để chỉ đạo phong trở cách mạng cảm nước.
Người đã trọn sát tên trào, làm thủ đối khu dài phống, cân cứ địa cách mạng.
Tại đây, Trung un đàn và bác hồ đã còn những quyết định quan trọng, lãnh đạo thành công cuộc tổ hửi ý sàng chính quyền trong cảm nước thẳng năm năm 1970.
Trời đến nay, tên trào vẫn đang thay đổi từng ngày với sĩnh bỏ mới đầy khử giả.
Tự hào với chuyển thống cách mạng, người dân tên trào luôn đoàn kết, lỗi lực phát triển kinh tế, đóng khóc xí dự quay hương, đưa tên trào trở thành sát đầu tiên của tình tên quan,
hòn thành xí dự nông hơn mới vào năm 1970 và đặt chuyển nông hơn mới nâng cao năm 1970.
Thù nhập bình quân độ người đặt gần năm 1970, thì lệ hộ gạo giảm con khoảng trên năm 1970.
Các thôn, đều có sân thiệt thao, giả văn hóa, tổ chức xin hoạt cộng thường suyên.
Tỳ lệ hộ gia đình đặt chuyển văn hóa đặt trên chiến mươi vấn trâm và 22, 22, 22, đều được công nhận là thuân văn hóa.
Tên trào đã và đang phát rủi đà lợi thế để chỉ đò của quý hương để phát triển các vạy hình dù lịch, cán tối văn hóa bản địa.
Tự nhiễm nhạc dạ sản chuyển thống, người dân đã cải tạo thành các Homestay đập chất xanh tục tài để phục vụ dù khác với các trả nghiệm như ăn cơm khẳng chiến, nha hát thêm, đi thuyền mằng chiến hồn nha nước, hãy chẻ tại lòng viện tân.
Vìa kết hợp lần ghép sữa một điều phát triển suy lịch và các điều chỉ sử dự nông hơn mới sẽ tạo thành độ lực phát triển nhanh hơn, hiệu quả hơn, qua đó khoảng bản định nhất đẹp văn hóa của đồng bảo dân tập thiệu số từ đó tạo thêm xinh kế cho bà con.
Sông hành với suy lịch, nông nghiệp cũng là chủ khổ thân trọng phát triển tinh tế của tân trào.
Đảng Uy chính quyền giá đặc biệt chủ trọng tinh chuyển và đậu ninh dân chuyển đổi cơ cấu kê trồng và nguy, áp dụng qua học kỹ thuật để nâng cao năng xuất và chức lượng sản phẩm.
Như sản phẩm nông nghiệp của địa phương đã đặt chuẩn ô cơm, hàng định thương hiệu và giá chi, nhiều mở đóng tân trào, đã ô cơm bà sau, dựa mên lá và đặc biệt là sản phẩm che vĩnh tân đặt chuẩn ô cơm muốn sao?
Tân trào hôm nay đang vân mình mạnh mẽ trở thành liểm sản về phát triển tinh tế sá hội trên nền tảng Bượng chắc của chuyển thống thách mạng.